across the country ordinary Americans
from all walks of life are taking
whatever measures necessary to prepare
we're preparing for a series of
terrorist attacks on the nuclear
facilities of this country for the
Yellowstone super volcano civil unrest
following a dirty bomb blast and protect
themselves
from what they perceived is the fast
approaching end of the world as we know
it
we go into the lives of three committed
Preppers who face a unique challenge
Preppers tend to prefer remote locations
rural tracks of land far from other
people and the chaos they fear will
erupt after an apocalyptic event for
them metropolitan areas are simply too
volatile too loaded with dangerous
variables but what happens when you live
and prep in the middle of America's most
densely populated city
in Brooklyn Cameron Moore a college
student studying for medical school
spends the time he's not in class
worrying about nuclear disaster
I'm preparing for a meltdown at the
Indian Point Nuclear facility Uptown in
Harlem Margaret Lang fears an act of
nature will destroy the city she grew up
in
I'm preparing for a catastrophic
hurricane
downtown on Wall Street Jay a bond
Trader who vividly remembers the day the
World Trade Center towers fell is
bracing from New York to be hit again
I'm preparing for another terrorist
attack
regardless of what form their doomsday
takes all three of these Preppers
believe they'll face the same challenge
you only have so many bridges leaving
New York City you're talking about
trying to get 8 million people out of
the city 30 million in the region the
Mayhem
the Panic Mass hysteria and the city
will be out of control it'll be every
man for himself at a certain point
a complete evacuation of Manhattan has
never been attempted if any large-scale
disasters dropped the city these
Preppers fear it might be impossible
the city's fragile system of bridges and
tunnels could become flooded jammed or
shut down within hours leaving Millions
trapped on a 23 square mile island
without access to food fresh water or
electricity
that's why for these three New York
Preppers at the first sign of trouble
survival comes down to one objective get
out of New York City leaving Manhattan
as soon as possible grab my bag
and just jet out they've also paired
with a mentor to help them refine their
plan Krav Maga instructor Matan gavish
preparedness expert
Eton Edwards and urban survivalist Shane
hobo
now over the course of one night all
three Preppers will put their bug out
plans into action for the first time an
attempt to escape New York
foreign
and again in October of 2012 New Yorkers
faced an unthinkable possibility
a direct hit from a hurricane
with Manhattan sitting only five feet
above sea level at points and experts
warning the storm surge could rise up to
15 feet 370
000 New Yorkers suddenly faced the
possibility that their homes would be
destroyed and their lives endangered
for Margaret Lange who recently moved to
New York City from Florida Rising Waters
and panic remind her of 2005 when she
was trapped in her home during Hurricane
Katrina I lived through it and I don't
want to live through it again and feel
vulnerable
currently there is a 1 in 75 chance that
a major hurricane will hit the region in
any given year a disastrous hurricane
hitting the city would just be horrific
and
it will knock out power it's happened
before so Margaret lives every day all
day with hundreds of dollars of survival
supplies literally strapped to her back
every day I make sure I carry a bag or a
backpack for me it's part of my training
hurricane warnings are usually issued
days before landfall but a last minute
change in direction or wind strength
could leave Margaret with only a few
hours notice
if a storm is coming Margaret doesn't
plan to follow FEMA instructions and
stay inside she'll use the window of
opportunity to escape I know I don't
want to be sent to a shelter I plan to
get out of the city and make my way up
to the mountains in Upstate New York
close to Canada the last and worst case
scenario is walking the entire distance
to safety up in the mountains
Margaret feels confident she can
physically withstand a long journey on
foot
but her greatest fear isn't running out
of energy
it's that she'll be vulnerable to
attacks from Desperate people who might
take her for an easy target as a woman
you're more likely to be victimized so I
want to be able to fend for myself
Margaret isn't confident she's prepared
for an apocalyptic street fight so she's
turning to Matan gavish a Krav Maga
expert who teaches the official no holds
bar defense system of the Israeli Army
prepping for disasters especially
catastrophic storms I want to know how
to defend myself when people go
ballistic on each other okay well you
come to the right place to prepare for
violence according to the principles of
Krav Maga avoiding a fight is always the
first and best form of self-defense
before she learns to attack Matan
believes Margaret must first learn to
preempt to confrontation by making
herself invisible you have to First
dress a lot less conspicuous he would
attract a lot of bad attention with this
type of outfit you have something more
comfortable less contiguous you can put
on definitely is that your bag yes yes
all right let's open it up and see
what's inside
antibacterial wipes the trowel okay in
case I have to do my business in case I
have to try through water I have a
bathing suit this is a nice little
device
a handsaw in case I have to build
anything
I can take down Lumber and start sawing
up to three years of sales service and
not even a tenth of that you can
probably lower this bag by half the
bigger the bag the more attention you
will get to yourself trying to get out
of an urban environment
people will want what's in that bag if
you'll be able to learn how to use your
environment
to provide for you then a lot of these
things will become
just added weights you'll be able to do
practically everything that you can do
with this with something like this
without much I can just you know put it
in my pocket and that's it I'm not
attracting any attention to myself so
right now I might not look like I'm
carrying anything of value on me or
anything that can sub for a self-defense
tool but I have not just one
but actually
three
of these great tools you do carry a
knife on me every day also Matan wants
Margaret to understand that if she pulls
out her knife she must be ready to use
it within seconds
if she hesitates a stronger opponent
could take it and use it against her
it takes a certain kind of individual to
be able to drive a knife into a person
it's not the same as punching a person
and it's not the same he's even shooting
a person driving a knife into another
human being
requires a certain
amount of evil inside of you now do you
think you'll be able to drive a knife
into someone's heart
as an alternative Matan has offered to
Show Margaret has some innocent looking
items in her bag can double his weapons
my favorite item from all this is right
here the lollipop you close that up this
doesn't move anywhere it's not this part
striking into any soft tissue into in
the body the eyes the cheeks cut right
through the blood and air vessels into
the throat get it in and out in and out
in and out as you strike you can cause a
lot of damage with this lollipop very
deadly tonight the town is going to
coach Margaret through a test run of her
plan to escape New York in advance of a
deadly hurricane mark it looks like a
tough girl or everything I've seen today
I think she will be able to do it she's
not gonna break she's been preparing for
this but we're going to put her through
some sticky situations absolutely in
2012 some of Margaret's worst fears were
realized as Hurricane Sandy sent cars
floating down Wall Street submerged
roadways on either side of the island
and flooded some subway tunnels from
tracks to ceiling so she and Matan are
plotting a 14-mile bug out route on foot
she's decided to walk through the parks
at the center of the island towards the
city's highest elevations near the
George Washington Bridge you ready to do
it I'll wait let's go all right all
right
foreign
[Music]
to train for a worst case scenario
they'll start from Battery Park City the
farthest point on the island from
Margaret's destination and the lowest
elevation point in the city
all right Margaret we have 14 miles to
go north you ready to do it let's go
let's go the clock has started on
Margaret's Journey
but while she's taking care to avoid the
water's edge college student Cameron
Moore is plotting to use the water to
his Advantage if a nuclear accident
makes New York uninhabitable but his
attempt to bug out by sea could be more
deadly than the apocalypse he fears
[Music]
these three New York City preppers are
convinced the city they Love Faces
imminent destruction they fear a
hurricane a terrorist attack or in the
case of student Cameron Moore a nuclear
accident that will destroy New York and
[ __ ] the global economy Cameron grew
up traveling the world as a teenager he
took humanitarian missions to India
Gabon and the Amazon now at the age of
23 he's made a life for himself in the
concrete jungle of New York I live in
New York because it's New York it's a
beautiful dirty place
but if the Indian Point Nuclear facility
which sits 35 miles north of the city
suffers a meltdown Cameron fears New
York would quickly become deadly the
official plans open up welcome centers
which are essentially detention centers
I mean you saw what happened to Katrina
you go into there it's martial law
people get killed and raped in those
centers and you can't leave you have no
individual Freedom the Indian Point
power nuclear reactor has over 1500 tons
of radioactive waste theoretically
anything above a 6.0 earthquake would
cause damage and you know just last year
here in New York City we had a 5.2 just
imagine how much of those Isotopes will
get would get into your body in the
event of even a minor spill
when Indian Point was built more than 40
years ago Engineers did not know it
rested on the intersection of active
seismic zones
if an earthquake caused a meltdown at
Indian Point
it forced the evacuation of nearly 20
million people
millions of people dying
is almost the low end of the impact if
New York City goes down
the United States economy goes down the
global economy goes down and we have a
serious worldwide problem that needs to
be dealt with when it's the fan I will
bug out
as a young beginning prepper Cameron
feels he needs a mentor to get him ready
we need to get you out of here
over to here and then across from here
so he's reached down for help from Eton
Edwards head of the international
preparedness Network and a prepper for
more than 25 years Akon is kind of a
versatile
preparedness expert uh he knows a little
bit of everything and a lot about some
things he can be intense you're not
going to want to stay in Brooklyn you're
not going to want to stay in the peak
injury zone so if you can get out of the
peak injury area in time before the
crowds make and you have a greater
chance of survival without uh you know
being irradiated glowing in the dark
it's cool to glow in the dark but it's
not very fun with the side effects that
come along with it if the Indian Point
nuclear reactor suffers a meltdown
Cameron believes he will only have five
hours before radiation hits the city
Cameron will avoid the Waterfront near
his home at the Brooklyn Bridge because
the currents there are three times
stronger and he risks being taken out to
sea he is planning to cut across
Manhattan for Speed and cross the Hudson
River to the mainland of New Jersey
shortest distance between two points is
what straight line there you go when we
get to the other side of Manhattan we
got to get across the Hudson River
that's where we're going to get creative
all right you ready for that I'm ready
tonight Aton will put Cameron through a
dry run of his plan in the middle of the
night
yo cam what's up get up man you gotta go
cell phone use in the United States
increased 100 after the 9 11 attacks
Aton expects that number to explode and
calls to be impossible if Indian Point
melts down so he's equipped Cameron with
a walkie-talkie to keep by his bedside
what's the situation
get up get rolling and meet me in the
park as quickly as you can
fire escape don't take the stairs
there's too many people coming down at
once they're getting jammed up you read
all right
situation like this you've got to do the
right things you've got to carry the
right things you've got to know where
you're going you've got to know how to
get there
what's up man
ah you made it we'll see what you've got
so I can get you ready to get out of
here as quickly as you can what kind of
ID I got my passport I got my social
security card passport is considered to
be about like the top grade ID you're
going to be able to move through
checkpoints easier with that kind of an
ID what about your potassium iodide
because you'd need that if you were
coming across with any inhale at
particulate one of the first things that
it can do is to attack the thyroid so
you want to have a thyroid Blocker in
there as well the only thing Brothers is
you know that anything that you leave
you've left because in a serious
radiological emergency chances are
you're not going to get back to that
area to get it ever again so recognize
what you have in that bag is the last of
whatever you left in that apartment
everything that's in that apartment is
going to be a museum at that point a
museum of uh what we shouldn't do ever
again let's roll out
Cameron's initial plan was to complete
his 13-mile journey on foot a challenge
for a non-athlete after an hour on the
street fatigue setting in by biking Aton
expends up to five times less energy
than Cameron on foot now he wants to see
if Cameron has the adaptability and
moral flexibility he considers necessary
to change his situation this is like a
quite a bit before we get to the
Brooklyn Bridge now I have an idea
if you're ready to go along with it
I think we're going to have to go and
find a bicycle because there's really no
way that she's going to be able to last
much longer at this pace I got the tools
I got the way
if you got the will let's make it happen
no I got it all right and let's do it
then
Chain's too thick
too thick we need something quick man
it's quick and fifth look at this one
right here
many Preppers bug out bags contain food
water and a weapon
bag contains bolt cutters which can cut
through industrial strength locks you
know what right now we've got to get out
of the city so it's a matter of survival
unfortunately sometimes the decisions
that you have to make when you want to
survive are pretty harsh this is the
reality of the situation Cameron is a
principled guy and I think that he would
hesitate unfortunately it's the kind of
a thing where you say he who hesitates
or she who hesitates is lost a man is
dying or and he his wife breaks into a
pharmacy because she can't afford the
medication and steals the medicine is
she morally right stealing a bicycle to
save your life or someone else's life is
uh
certainly acceptable it was something I
would consider
while Cameron is picking up speed
downtown on Wall Street a third New York
prepper is getting ready for a different
kind of Apocalypse for Jay who asked we
can seal his last name for professional
reasons doomsday already happened once
in his lifetime he vividly remembers
being in Manhattan on September 11 2001.
experiencing the the Attacks of
September 11th that it's just horrifying
it also makes you really aware how
vulnerable you are and of course my
first thoughts are is this happening is
it going to continue to happen and
where's my family Jay's working on a
plan to protect his family from more
terrorist attacks but the stress of
reliving his worst nightmare maybe more
than he can handle
foreign
preppers are on a simultaneous bug out
Margaret Ling who is learning to fight
for her life without a rulebook pre-med
student Cameron Moore who must choose
between helping others and saving
himself
and Jay who fears any hesitation after a
terrorist attack might mean he'll never
see his family again when it came to the
terrorist attacks in New York City the
big problem was just the total confusion
and the realization of the horror of are
we really going through this or is this
just some type of surrealistic nightmare
that's happening
no event in recent history shattered
American sense of safety more than the
terrorist attacks of 9 11. for a number
of Americans like Jay it was the major
Catalyst to start prepping I don't think
it's gonna
end I don't think that we're going to
wake up all of a sudden one day and
of some we're not going to be a Target
terrorists around the world a dirty bomb
is without question and an option for
terrorists out there if a dirty bomb
containing conventional explosives and
radioactive material were detonated in
the middle of Manhattan hundreds could
die immediately with more casualties
possible in the aftermath Jay fears that
if millions of New Yorkers tried to flee
the radiation they'd find the city's
Bridges and tunnels incapable of
handling a mass Exodus those without a
concept of what to do and where to go
and
what their first step should be are
way behind the game
Jay has spent around five thousand
dollars assembling a cache of supplies
kept in his home in the place he thinks
he's most likely to be during the next
attack the attack during 1993 and
certainly September 11th were during
business hours and business days so if
indeed I had the bug out of my office
and get Uptown I'd go to be prudent that
I have a well-stocked bugatt bag
if terrorists detonate dirty bombs
across Manhattan as Jay fears he's
instructed his wife Mindy and their
six-year-old daughter to get ready to
flee the city
on September 11 2001 the city's Bridges
and tunnels were shut down 36 minutes
after the attacks so if Jay is at work
he believes he must be able to get home
to his family as soon as possible or
they must be ready to leave without him
my daughter she thinks it's a game to a
certain extent I try to make it the game
escape New York will make it fun but Jay
doesn't believe his white collar job in
finance has set him up with physical
skills he needs to meet his family and
get out of New York as quickly as
possible
so recently he started giving up
weekends to train with Shane Hobel an
expert who teaches urban survival
classes in Central Park
I just started working with a gentleman
who's become a manner learning about
various urban tactics and things one
should watch out for and look for
when you're in a big city like Manhattan
let's pull up the map okay and let's
take a look at a path of travel between
this place this work site and your
family we want to get to your family
immediately right this is the objective
exactly right to get to them and then to
do the bug out from that point forward
have you ever done this walk before I
had to take the swap once before right
after 9 11. you know at that point
you know the the the city was an
absolute pandemonium and uh and it was
very chaotic so we just hooked it right
up town right why don't we take a look
at what you have in your go bag okay and
uh see what you're carrying see the
weight of it okay and uh and let's go
from there let's take a look at what we
got I've got a rain poncho I have a fire
starter communication so I can get in
touch with my wife first aid kit pry bar
in case things get tough to get out very
good so looking at this and the amount
of weight for which it's carrying you
know there's some stuff in here we can
probably lighten up on Shane believes
there is one item in Jay's bag that
weighs less than a quarter pound but
which could help him meet almost all his
survival needs and replace many of the
heavier items in his bag
I'm going to show you what to do
with one of these when you don't have
any of this stuff
Shane and Jay are plotting a way to
escape his office in lower Manhattan and
head for a secret rendezvous point in
the Upper East Side where his wife and
daughter will be waiting
from there the family will make their
way out of Manhattan into queens and
then to the Hamptons at the tip of Long
Island where they have established a
safe house in an undisclosed location
I try to explain to my daughter
you know the idea of the terrorist
attack life's not whoa one big
playground
if a dirty bomb attack happens Shane
doesn't believe Jay should walk a
straight line to his family as there
could be radioactive elements drifting
across the city
so his first lesson is a method that
will help guide Jay home so now the
first thing we need to double check here
is one trick the wind right we're
dealing with an Airborne situation
potential uh Hazard there so one thing
we can do is just at street level at our
level you know we're checking the wind
obviously we've got some wind coming in
from that direction and we blow it out
and we notice where the smoke is it's
heading in that direction if Jay is able
to pinpoint the location of the dirty
bomb explosion Shane recommends he tests
the movement of the air and then walk
into the wind this will give him the
greatest chance of getting the Airborne
Hazard behind him as quickly as possible
by paying attention to all the little
Telltale such as that as trees banners
flags high wire cables any of the uh the
window rigging stuff anything that would
indicate movement of the wind that's
going to help guide us through the city
so in this example we would immediately
cross the street have that wind towards
our face allowing that Hazard to be be
blowing behind us and then we would move
so throughout the course of tonight this
is something we have to pay attention to
at all times let's do this
if as Jay fears Lower Manhattan is
filled with toxic smoke when he emerges
from his office he may need to drink as
much water as possible to help his body
rehydrate and keep him moving towards
his goal but if stores are shut down
after a terrorist attack the only
available water might be sitting in
places like this
a fountain exposed to the elements and
often played in by children
Shane believes Jay needs the skills to
make even the dirty parts of the city
his Lifeline I'm going to show you a
little trick about filtering water on
the Fly
let's see what we got here okay let's
see the bandana of yours so we're going
to take this charcoal it's just clean
charcoal from a campfire right no
chemicals nothing else involved so we're
assuming that the wind has been blowing
in our favor that it hasn't affected
this area including this water source so
the same bandana that is now going to
help us filter this water here's the
trick we can't use these large pieces of
charcoal it's not going to filter
anything the water is simply going to
run in and around and all of this stuff
we need to make this absolutely powder
like confection sugar and so
pound this up see that beautiful dust
that's coming out that's what we want
because if it's coming out of the
bandana well I know that it's going to
be pretty pulverized inside this bandana
as the fountain water is poured over the
charcoal chlorine sediment and other
substances that would make it
undrinkable chemically bind to the
charcoal and are removed
Shane recommends every prepper carry
charcoal in their bug out bag for an
easy inexpensive and effective water
filter
let's do this
feels good to hydrate huh
tasty yeah huh let's go
this is not just a journey of getting to
his family but the truth is it's a
discovery a journey to himself and
understanding where the strength lies
within all three New York City preppers
are now on the move before the night is
over Jay will find out if he has the
physical stamina necessary to be his
family's hero Cameron will learn to
sacrifice his desire to help people and
strike if necessary and Margaret is
about to discover that dropping one's
guard in a doomsday situation can be
fatal
foreign
over the course of one night three New
York City preppers are putting their bug
out plans to the test and attempting to
escape the island of Manhattan
now their mentors are about to Spring
their biggest challenges
you always want to be aware people
usually get into trouble when they're in
parks at night during Hurricane Sandy
water surged a record 13 feet to flood
areas on both sides of the island so
Margaret believes her best choice is to
walk through the center of the city
including parks that she fears could
become hotbeds for conflict this is what
I was talking about earlier when I was
talking about awareness you want to see
violence before it begins these two guys
I don't like the way they behave it's
gonna get violent it's better for us to
just go around it not get anywhere near
it let's just get out of here okay okay
only engage in violence if you cannot
avoid the situation by 4 AM Matan and
Margaret have walked six miles and
reached the base of Central Park
in her scenario gale force winds could
be Roaring Waters may have already risen
on either side of Manhattan and she
fears Central Park may be one of the
only dry land masses left here without
her knowledge Matan is about to test how
prepared she is to defend herself this
is your test
I want you to meet me at the most
northern part of the park I'm Gonna Let
You Go now good luck and I'll see you on
the other side Matan is watching
Margaret to see if she employs awareness
strategies
keep her head up scan back and forth
focus on the whole scene not get tunnel
vision for only what is in front of her
and be aware of what lies ahead and
behind
thank you
thank you
[Applause]
it's Margaret what went wrong I didn't
pay enough attention during my route
not enough awareness right
did you see the one person coming behind
you saw one I heard him
I was trying to avoid him I heard the
footsteps but I was not aware there was
a second guy when we're dealing with
attackers we can never assume there is
only one person but also when you were
grabbed
it froze you started wrestling out but
there were no strikes there was no
marking into soft points there were none
of the stuff that would actually get you
to take down a bigger stronger assailant
so let's take out the lollipop
all right if this is the only thing
that's on you you'd already be prepared
if you're walking in a dark Park in the
middle of the night by yourself
you should have something ready to go
you were caught from behind in the bear
hug
all right from here you attempted to try
to wrestle him off of you I had idea
drop your weight shift your hips grab
the groin grab grab the second you get
that distance
that's where the lollipop comes in turn
around Hammer face cross right into the
throat with lollipop puncture the throat
the eyes the throat the face only into
soft tissues strike
they get into the ear into the eyes get
out of there
okay all right
so now let's have you do it you get grab
from behind
drop your way down the other side open
Palm to the groin elbow to the body good
now Hammer fist keep working lollipop
goes only to soft points left hand
strike right hand strikes working on all
the soft points getting him out push him
off and out of there out out out out out
out all right so you see how easy it was
for you to move and strike and get away
without that big bag weighing you down
you don't need all that equipment all
you need is a good instrument to step
with it could be your lollipop could be
a knife and a bottle of water that is it
and when you're walking through
Manhattan at night it's not the big
storm you have to worry about it's the
flock of crazy people that are going to
try to put their hands on you I just
have to spend more time and be
put more work into being in the gym in
practice one is the only two essential
fighting off ending off three four
people at one time it's just something I
have to do to be prepared despite her
setback in the park and being an hour
behind her goal
Margaret wants to see her bug out
through to the end she will continue on
through Harlem and towards her
destination at the George Washington
Bridge further downtown Aton and Cameron
are just arriving at the base of the
Brooklyn Bridge Cameron fears by now two
hours into his journey Panic will have
set in for people on the island so
before they get to Manhattan atan
showing Cameron his favorite tool for
disabling assailants
in New York people fight the problem
with that is is that an emergency like
this you can't afford to get into a
physical conflict because of a lot of
different reasons one of which is that
you don't have the time and the energy
of the inclination you're trying to get
out you're not trying to fight and prove
that you're Mike Tyson what I would
suggest is something that you can use
spray
or attack somebody because if you try to
fight with your fist a lot of energy is
lost so you know what I like
I like to carry
stuff like this you know what this is
you wouldn't believe it
bear detergent yeah man bear deterrent
yeah you know what it is this is mace
for like animals
Eton carries bear repellent instead of
pepper spray typically used for defense
against human attackers the two have the
same ingredients and both cause
debilitating pain and blindness but
because bear spray is formulated to take
down adult Grizzlies it is more potent
shoots farther and can incapacitate
multiple human attackers now if you aim
to defy this in somebody's face or if
you aimed and fired this in the general
direction of somebody you'd wind up
doing a lot of damage to basically stun
and run what are you trying to do stun
and run
foreign
wants to push Cameron to see if he has
the mental and physical fortitude to
survive an all-night Escape From New
York but the next surprise he Springs
may push Cameron over the edge
as night is turning in today three New
York City preppers are in the midst of
grueling tests of their survival skills
to see if they'll have what it takes to
escape New York's Urban Jungle when
doomsday comes by now in a worst case
scenario Margaret Ling fears up to 11
percent of Manhattan could be underwater
Jay has followed a Meandering path to
escape the dirty bomb debris he fears
but it has already taken him six hours
to go from Wall Street to Midtown with
the most congested parts of the city
still to go and Cameron has crossed one
of Manhattan's rivers and now has
another mile to reach the Hudson he
fears that if nuclear fallout Rains Down
on the city this brief Passage through
Manhattan will be the most dangerous he
will need to cross a city packed with
millions of panicked and potentially
Violent New Yorkers
earlier in the night Aton urged Cameron
to steal a bicycle
now they'll both find out if Cameron is
ready to pull the trigger on his own I
was raised Quaker I believe in you know
when pacifism non-violence
I'm against killing people
I would try to just stop
Cam's got a lot of spirit
and I think cam will fight and then
he'll worry about what he did later on
can you see this watch yourself
good shot on the bike let's roll move
out
stun and run stand and run let's go with
eton's help Cameron proved he has the
will to strike an assailant and keep
moving
but he doesn't know the moral dilemmas
he faced tonight were orchestrated by
Aton
he also doesn't know that his biggest
challenge is very real and just around
the corner this is where I'm gonna break
off from cam pretty soon he doesn't
really know it but he's got to kind of
like stand on his own two feet at this
point and now we've come to the moment
of truth and that is we've gotten to
Manhattan now we've got to get to New
Jersey and the only way to do that is to
cross that River while Cameron plans his
River Crossing 50 blocks away
foreign
Jay and Shane have less than a mile left
to go this is also the last stop before
they enter what many consider New York's
most chaotic 14 blocks Times Square
as he would in a real bug out after a
terrorist attack Jay will attempt to
contact his wife before entering this
final high-risk stretch
he'll use a two-way radio which FEMA
agents use themselves when they enter a
catastrophe where phone lines may be
jammed
Mindy Mindy's Jay over
I'm on Grandma's block the car is packed
and we're ready to go that's right
Grandma's house I'll see you there soon
love you guys
good deal you know I just wanted to
point out we're out in the open right
now right we've got plenty of trees
across the street those banners that
street sign over there we're getting a
change of the wind so far so good we can
feel it in our face
right that's a good advantage that
Airborne threat that dirty bomb is
behind us we're in a good position let's
head up north
up to 1.6 million people pass through
Times Square every day
Shane worries that is that if crowds
gather here after a terrorist attack Jay
may get hurt as he tries to push through
to get to his family he wants to show
Jay that if he's injured a natural field
Hospital stands just off Times Square
and on his way home
so this bandana I remember we've been
using for all along well you know we can
use this for first aid application
splinting for uh for any sort of slings
anything along that compression bandages
right here
on this field as it is we've got
plantain you familiar with this plant
absolutely yeah it's inedible yes you
know that you can actually make this
into an incredible antiseptic if you get
a cut a laceration any member of your
family you grab this plant make sure
that it's clean I could take some of
this plant right now and chew on it I'm
gonna get a nice pulp right
my saliva is activating this medicinal
property place it right on the wound
I would take a brand new Leaf of the
same plant you know lay it right over
the top of it as if it was the bandage
take that bandana just like any other
bandage
now I've got myself a field dressing
plantain it'll save your life
Jay's Journey has taken him through the
night now he will have to make one final
push to see his family
for Margaret and Cameron the Moment of
Truth has also arrived each of them is
about to hit their limits and face the
final test that will determine if they
have any hope of surviving Doomsday
as the Sun starts to rise three New York
City preppers are nearly off the island
and away from the apocalyptic Urban
landscape they fear
Cameron has to get across the Hudson
River Margaret is determined to make it
across the George Washington Bridge
and Jay must rendezvous with his family
and complete the bug out to Long Island
with him
honey we just arrived in the park I
should be there in a few minutes over
terrific I'll see you soon
all right there's a bond right down here
clean yourself off right
get yourself back together
okay
[Music]
nice good job
well done thank you thank you thanks for
all your help
I think you did a fantastic job I think
it was a big reality check in terms of
what he needs to work on but you know
Jay's got a big heart and he's got a
huge objective and that's his beautiful
family well the last leg of the journey
was exhausting to say the least but I
knew ultimately that my family was real
close and that's what kept me going
going forward I'm certainly going to
continue with my basic prepping plans
all right let's get out of here
but if it's something that's absolutely
horrific and the end of times
post-apocalyptic nightmare well then
it's most likely game over
I guess at that point I'll make sure I
have three bullets left
The Hamptons at the tip of Long Island
are known as a playground for the rich
and famous in summer months
the house Jay's family has there isn't a
weekend getaway Jay believes most New
Yorkers will travel West towards the
mainland of New Jersey to escape dirty
bomb debris so he is making the opposite
decision to move East towards the ocean
Jay's bug out vehicle is not only
equipped with all his family supplies
but also three bicycles so if the family
encounters roadblocks along the way they
can abandon their car and still have a
way to reach their safe house as far as
the safety of my family is concerned
there's pretty much nothing that I
wouldn't do I would certainly put my
life
on the line for theirs
on the other side of the city Margaret
is about to walk out of Manhattan and
over the George Washington Bridge into
New Jersey
with 14 Lanes the greatest carrying
capacity of any bridge in the world she
believes it's best equipped to absorb
the masses of panicked New Yorkers she
fears will be attempting to flee the
city with her
by now Margaret is ours over her ideal
escape window in her scenario the bridge
would have already been shut down due to
high winds and Waters would have risen
several feet around the island
she would be trapped
all right Margaret this is the end of
the line for me from here you're on your
own good luck
bye-bye well I didn't make it here at
Sunrise but we did pause a few times so
I think that added more time to the
journey and since my guard was so down
because I thought my town will take care
of everything I kind of just let all
that responsibility go after tonight's
experience I'm definitely going to
practice more evening walks and I'm
gonna Pray for Peace but prepare for war
10 miles south of Margaret at the George
Washington Bridge
the final leg of Cameron's Escape From
New York is also the most strenuous
he'll attempt to cross the Hudson River
into New Jersey cutting across an 8 500
foot stretch of water with currents that
run both ways
the idea was to get Cam out and get him
into a safe area then cam is well on his
way into getting out of the city and out
of Harm's Way all right dude you ready
you ready I'm really proud of him you
know proud to have him as a friend and
I'm proud of just how he's been able to
kind of move through all of this tonight
Pizza all right cam do it man I'll see
you there
he's good for the game he's going to
make a great doctor but he'd also would
have made a great marine and a great
Soldier as well
in the event of an actual storm I
believe Margaret will be able to make
her way out of New York City she does
have to keep working a lot on her
self-defense skills
overall I think he's starting to get it
I think what he realizes is how far he
has to dig deep to push himself
physically and mentally keeping the
objective in mind
it's important to prepare I don't think
anyone can ever be prepared enough Atari
showed me the way I couldn't have done
it without a time if there ever is an
Indian Point Nuclear meltdown I'll be
able to find a way out most likely make
it to safety the vast majority of people
will have that luxury
Jersey the promised land feeling
exhilarated
tired but exhilarated
[Music]
New York has seen a handful of
significant hurricanes in the last 200
years on average experts predict that a
major hurricane will hit the region
every 74 years
2012's Hurricane Sandy tested local
emergency plans even as New York
suffered tremendous damages its citizens
largely remained orderly
the Indian Point facility received top
safety ratings in 2011 from the nuclear
Regulatory Commission but in 2012 it
still needs to meet post Fukushima
safety standards and many remain
concerned
New York has faced terrorist attacks in
the past since 2001 the state has
received more than 3 billion dollars in
federal Homeland Security funding and
New York City police officers currently
carry thousands of radiation detectors
[Music]
thank you